[Musique]
il se développe à la Réunion depuis 2006
et s'associe au mouvement hip hop pour
le pratiquer il suffit de deux cordes et
d'une bonne équipe car ici tout est
question de rythme et de coordination
mais aussi de complicité et de
solidarité et là les conditions sont
réunies pour effectuer des figures
acrobatiques démonstration à la
possession j mine que je lounéù
lesour c'est Johnny Mel j'ai 18 ans je
fais dou depuis il fait 4
ANSI c'est jy du double depuis 4
ans bonjour moi c'est jean-an et pareil
je su
[Musique]
dou alors ben moi c'est Sadon Bertrand
je su intervenant double dutch gratter
mon paradis à sans le regretter pour
faire le tour de la terre je n'ai pas
l'éternité malgré tout je reste l'fant
au
rimité à part entière il a sa fédération
internationale et ses championnats de
France le double dutch a aussi une
dimension social son slogan le
résume traduction les cordes pas la
drogue en France comme aux États-Unis
c'est un outil de prévention et
d'éducation qui permet à toute une
génération de faire du sport sans exiger
une grosrastr
dem mon dans les et avoir l'endurance
et faut pas avoir peur aussi pour lancer
les figures et toutoud m'échapp sur
leisant qui MRA de le plaisir de
pratiquer un sport qui existe pas
forcément pas toucher la réunée on
peut après on peut justement ben montrer
que il y a d'autres sport que les sports
connus déjà sur
l'île l'air de rien les frères Mirel ont
déjà décroché des podiums champion de
France en 2009 et vice-champion de
France en 2010 ils ont même participé au
Championnat du Monde à Paris en équipe
de France en compétition il y a
plusieurs catégories les détails tout de
suite c'est de tourneurs un sauteur ou
deux tourneurs de sauteurs et le but
c'est d'entrer dans les cordes de sauter
de selon les épreuves faire so le plus
grand nombre de pas ou les épreuves de
freestyle où là ça consiste à faire des
des figures dans les cordes mélangeant
acrobatie hip hop gymnastique ou danse
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cetera le double dutch ça vient des des
États-Unis à la base ils ont ils ont
emmené ça dans les dans les ghetos les
policiers ils ont commencé à emmener ça
dans les getos pour faire une activité
justement pour pour les enfants traînent
pas quoi cé une activité nouvelle et
petit à petit c'est devenu une
discipline ben internationale maintenant
ça s'est beaucoup développé
là-bas la Réunion compte de clubs
chapauté par lufolet tout le monde est
bienvenu à partir de l'âge de 6
ans alors les lieux à la Réunion
vraiment on va dire là où il y a le plus
de pratiquants ben c'est à la possession
au tampon après ben depuis 4 ans comme
on a essayé de développer l'activité à
la Réunion il y a quelques intervenants
sur d'autres quartiers de l'île qui qui
pratique mais pas régulièrement quoi
donc vraiment à la possession au
[Musique]
tampon savoir c'est quoi le double
ession et nous bien les
bien moiême et
[Musique]
voilà